I will be staying away from spoilers in
this video so if you haven't read the
book or seen the 1989 version of the
film you're still safe here I will
discuss the lore and explain a few minor
plot details that happen early on if you
want to know the meaning of the spiral
on the tree then stick around to the end
of this video this video is sponsored by
wondershare filmora it's a great option
if you're looking to get into editing
videos and you're just a beginner you
can just drag your videos right into the
timeline and the program comes with
music transitions filters and effects
you can also get more assets from the
film or effects store like the new
creepy Halloween pact I'll be using
those effects in this video so if you're
interested be sure to visit the link in
the description it looks like 2019 is
gonna be an awesome year for Stephen
King fans with Pet Sematary and it
chapter two on the way and if you follow
my channel in 2017 you'll know it was
one of the first big things you missed
episodes to get super popular so today
we'll be taking a drive down the road
from Derry Maine to Ludlow Maine to take
a look at all of the things you missed
in the new trailer for Pet Sematary
Roy hominy trace it's beautiful right
it's definitely not Boston that's right
it looks like the cria family moves to
Maine from Boston in this movie as
opposed to Chicago where they're from in
the book
Chicago is also where the parents of the
wife Rachel Creed live there's further
evidence in the family's Massachusetts
license plate and Lewis's Cape Cod shirt
which also has the year 2016 printed on
it signaling that the 2019 version will
be at or at least near present-day just
like it chapter 2 which will be set in
2016 the time period may also hold a
clue as to why the family is now from
Boston instead of Chicago in the book
which takes place in the 80s there's a
scene where Rachel needs to quickly get
back home while visiting her parents in
Chicago she ends up booking a series of
connecting flights and there's even a
scene in the 1989 movie where she runs
through the terminal to board a flight
that has already closed its doors in a
post-911 setting however none of that is
as realistic so the family may be
located out of Boston so that Maine is
just a drive away rather than a flight
away Boston's Logan International
Airport is the closest airport to Maine
that rachel is able to get to in the
book and she ends up driving from there
to her home so making the family from
Boston in this movie just simplifies
that journey hear that cry in the
background that's the cry of the wendigo
a mythological cryptid said to be
located in the northeastern United
States the Wendigo is one of the better
known Native American legends said to be
a human cannibals transformed over time
into a giant bipedal deer like creature
that eats human flesh in Pet Sematary
the book the one to go curse the Mi'kmaq
tribe burial ground in Ludlow granting
it the power to bring those who are
buried there back to life as undead
cannibals we don't actually get to see
the one to go in the 1989 movie but
there may be a clue in the 2019 trailer
that it will make an appearance this
time I'll get back to that later on in
this video
so the drums played by the animal mask
children represent the tribal music of
the Mi'kmaq tribe and the cry heard in
the distance could be the one to go
speaking of the kids in the animal masks
what's the deal with that as far as I
can remember there are no such kids in
the book so who are they in the book
there are a couple of old stories told
by dr. Creed's neighbor Judd Crandall
when he first shows them the pet
cemetery he explains that it was created
by kids who had lost their pets trucks
on the dangerous road that the town is
situated on
my guess is that this is just a
flashback scene showing the kids burial
ritual for their pets the trailer is cut
to make it look like Rachel and Ellie
actually see the kids funeral procession
but I don't think that the actual movie
will be cut like that just speculating
hearing but I think they're using the
clips out of context we also get to see
the family's cat church who doesn't look
as creepy as the cat in the 1989 version
but there's a much stronger resemblance
to his appearance on the cover of the
book there is a pretty creepy moment
from the cat though and we'll talk about
it later in this video as i mentioned
the road outside the house is extremely
menacing this shot of a truck blazing
through seems to be an exact replica of
a shot used in the 1989 movie however
there is one noticeable difference the
license plate of this truck reads c6 1
the alphanumeric translation of which
says a cgi maybe this is a small hint
that this 2019 film will take advantage
of computer-generated imagery to do
things that the 1989 version wasn't able
to like show a realistic rendering of
the wendigo or show a more graphic
depiction of the scene those of you
familiar with the story know the one I'm
talking about but for all I know maybe
this is just a set of random letters and
numbers let me know what you think in
the comments the next thing I'd like to
point out is the scene here of Lewis
getting out of his bed and discovering
that his feet are covered in dirt in the
book this takes place right after he has
this dream where the ghost of one of his
former patients most likely this guy
brings him to the pet cemetery and warns
him to never cross in this barrier known
as the dead wood the divide between the
pet cemetery and the cursed burial
ground he wakes up at first relieved
that it was just a dream until his
daughter notices the smell and he
discovers his feet are covered in dirt
Lucis deceased patient and Victor
Pascale makes several appearances to
Rachel in the 80s a movie adaptation and
that looks to also be the case in 2019
remember when I first talked about the
trailer for its and pointed out that
penny wises eyes were at the time
missing from the reflection in the water
if you look closely at penny wises
reflection right here you'll notice that
its eyes don't seem to reflect in the
water which is pretty creepy if you ask
me yeah get a load of this hopefully
they don't end up replacing the eyes for
the final movie like they did for it
unless it ends up being even creepier
and then
Boyd one thing that was absent from the
1989 movie adaptation is a character
named Norma Crandall Judds
old arthritic wife who in the book
without spoiling anything is a central
part in setting the main events in
motion she's replaced by the caretaker
character Missy Dandridge in the 80s
movie but this quick shot in the trailer
could possibly mean that she'll have an
appearance in the upcoming film side
note the reason that I keep referring to
it as an upcoming movie is because I
always get these comments and my movie
trailer things you missed episodes that
say this is so stupid analyzing the
trailer why don't you just watch the
movie which I do almost always put out a
longer things you missed for the movie
as soon as it's out but for whatever
reason there's always that person who
ignores that episode and comes to
complain about the trailer analysis so
to those people watching this after
April 2019 why don't you just watch the
episode that I did on the movie the last
thing I'd like to talk about though from
the trailer is this image of the tree
with the spiral on it this is another
symbol that I don't remember being in
the first movie but it definitely is in
the book
Louis draws the shape in the dirt at one
of the graves with his finger without
even realizing that is doing so then
upon returning to the Mi'kmaq burial
ground he realizes the entire thing is
shaped like a spiral and wonders if
anyone had ever seen this land from
above so the spiral is a symbol of the
power that this cursed land has over the
town and its inhabitants continuing on
with the analogy - it's just as dairy
seems to have an overlooked history of
bad things happening to it that is
driven by the malevolence of Pennywise
Ludlow has a similar force presiding
over it driven by the power of the
Windigo
in other words the spiral is - Pet
Sematary what the red balloon is - it if
you're looking forward to seeing Pet
Sematary then we would like on this
video some of you may recall that the 89
film ended with an original song by the
Ramones
I highly doubt there would be another
song tie-in today but if there was what
modern punk band do you think would
perform it I imagine it would probably
be Fall Out Boy or something although
there is a certain other band rumored to
be returning in 2019 let me know your
thoughts in the comments I'll be
covering a bunch of topics related to
the new adaptations of Pet Sematary and
it so if you love Stephen King novels
then remember to subscribe to seize
these worlds from new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive